hi I'm Doug Walker from channel Lawson
at the end of our most popular show
nostalgia critic we always do a charity
shout out encouraging people to donate
well they've done well we realize not
everybody's in a financial situation
where they can give but everybody at
some point or another can't give time so
every month we're gonna try and show a
new charity or organization that you can
help out with there's so many people in
difficult circumstances but thankfully
there's always people who are willing to
help and you can be one of them whether
it's volunteering or lending a helping
hand we're here to show what you can do
[Music]
my name is Kelsey Liverpool and I am the
co-founder and executive director for
kids ranked we are program designed
specifically for military children our
pillars are connected and served we want
the kids to connect with each other to
work on leadership which a lot of them
innately have and then to be of service
to their communities
now what gave you the idea to do this is
a very unique idea I was a military
spouse for 17 years and so we lived all
over and I saw how adaptable my own kids
who are now 14 and 16 how they had to go
to new schools and kindergarten in
second grade they went to three
different schools I felt that they were
super resilient and I knew that it was
not just my own kids but military kids
on the website you say that they have to
deal with the ideas of sacrifice and
service without exactly knowing what
they mean yet my dad was in the Navy for
28 years and I just remarried we moved
around a lot and I liked that everyone
had to salute him but I didn't know
anything else about it and you very much
teach them what it means and show them
through a lot of these activities and
volunteering yeah I mean our groups are
called prides for a reason we want them
to have a sense of pride in in what
their parents do we are 1% of the
population it's an all-volunteer force
at this point and what is it that you're
going to be doing today today I'm
excited we're at Fort Sheridan Cemetery
former Army Post and we're going to be
placing flags for Memorial Day in
preparation for their Memorial Day
ceremony it's about remembering a lot of
our servicemembers are forgotten and so
this is a way of acknowledging who they
were and that they sacrifice their lives
some during service and some you know
once they became a veteran but just
remembering who they were when I came in
which was around 1970 at that point
people hated Vietnam couldn't take it
out on the government so they took it
out on the military people signs up dogs
and sailors stay off the law and stuff
like that so when I see things like this
and the military is now held in high
regard the flags mean that somebody is
remembering we meet weekly which is
really important there's so much
instability in the military as you know
going from place to place and you make a
friend and then it's time to go
so having that weekly connection but our
meetings are very structured to have
their own creed that they say they do PT
physical training we like to add
authentic military kind of tones and
culture to the work that we do and
service is such a big part of it so
their parents serve the country we want
the kids to serve their communities and
understand that it's not that something
that everybody does but it's a it's a
really positive way to get them out of
themselves and sometimes when you move
you become isolated we're in a world
that very much welcomes people that want
to be isolated with social media and the
internet and so on so forth so I really
like this idea that you bring these
groups together and just do good with it
and very much strengthen it feels like
something that strengthens kids yeah I
think it gives them a voice they have
other kids that understand what they're
going through so you know we always ask
at the beginning how many times you've
moved and will inevitably have a kid
that's like you know I'm 9 and I've
moved like seven times I think their
resiliency is really inspiring and it's
nice that the kids they don't have to
explain like if they move in the middle
of the school year there are other kids
that understand why you know why you've
moved in the middle of the school year
or that you have a parent that is maybe
geo Bachelor you know me you know that
goes in and does their duty but has to
leave their family at home why that is
what do you love about kids right
exercising do they do that a lot they do
a lot of exercising every day holy
smokes that's a yeah you're built man
you're built when we moved around a lot
there was always kind of this idea of
like wait so you've moved around this
many times even stayed in one place and
that seemed so foreign and I like I like
the idea very much saying that there's a
strength to it even though there's
downsides you very much point to the
positive side of it too
we are strength based at
I don't want them to feel sorry for
themselves or feel like it's something
that's a burden we want them to feel
that they're empowered by it this year
alone we volunteered for 15 different
organizations or have done 15 different
service projects one of our pride
members had a cousin with cancer and she
wanted to do a drive to collect toys for
children with cancer so we did that as a
group of homeless shelter where we go
and and help prep for a service night
you know to feed meals somebody came to
me and was looking for a way to give
back to military children and they
wanted to do like school supplies which
is really great but I felt like we
needed to do something that was
addressed a need for our kids so we
partnered with the Highland Park High
School Rotary Club and we put together
welcome and farewell kits for military
children we had a young man that moved
to Japan and I asked him you know are
you excited to go to Japan you know your
friends gonna miss you and he said
nobody's gonna even know I'm gone oh wow
and that's devastating and we don't want
that for our kids we don't want them to
feel like they're invisible and that
nobody cared that they were here so
these welcome and farewell kids give us
bring intention around you know
recognizing that that's a point of view
that most people would even think I
wouldn't think of that you know so to
see if from that angle and this or bring
that warmth on that strength I think is
just so wonderful and so it's an
opportunity to partner with our civilian
community you know they can get involved
in helping us put these kids together
I'm Kristin Skinner I'm a lieutenant
commander in the Navy I'm a nurse we've
been a part of it since 2015 and have
loved it and we loved having the
community love us and embrace us and
then we love to like give back so we've
done some stuff at the VA s with Ronald
McDonald House bringing flowers to the
vets at level so we've explained to the
kids that no Memorial Day isn't for us
they wear the uniform it's gross that
have given the ultimate sacrifice so we
can all barbecue and have our freedoms
in America adapting bravery courage
determination these are all things that
come about from being part of a military
family I love to see children feel like
they can give back because quite often
you know kids are saying you know goes
over there you know that you can't help
with this you can't do that this really
shows them that they can make a
difference the purpose of this show is
to demonstrate what people can do to
volunteer and then give their time what
are some ways that people can volunteer
for kids right then we have a whole
smorgasbord of kind of volunteer
opportunities depending on if you want
to come in just for a day or a specific
event or if you have time to to make
more of an impact once a month we do a
service project like this where we get
out into the community with another
organization we meet weekly during the
school year to come in and work with our
kids share a talent or a skill or
something like that we like to give our
kids opportunity for exposure and then
also we're always needing leaders the
most important thing for our kids at
this point is to provide consistency so
leaders that would be dedicated to come
in and work with them on a weekly basis
as a kids rank leader I helped lead the
group and so we have like a set
curriculum for throughout the year we
work on three ribbons and so in a
regular Club meeting we would start with
our kids aren't Creed and then we do PT
which is like exercising and then we
check in with the kids for their week
and how they're and see how they're
doing and then we do games based on the
ribbon that we're working on I love
interacting with the kids and learning
their stories and getting to meet them
because military children they know who
you know they move in and out of the
community and so being able to connect
with them is really meaningful in the
military service member when they
receive an accommodation or some sort of
recognition for service will get a
ribbon for kids rank our ribbons are
based on their positive qualities I
mentioned before a DAP bravery courage
we do a ceremony and they line up in
formation and they are pinned with their
ribbons sometimes we have other people
come
in them they love when their parents pin
them it's a you know it's a really
special moment but it's it brings
ceremony around their achievement and
it's mainly in Illinois right now okay
might expand expanding soon look for it
okay like this what they do that's what
they do they get strength amass what
sold out and if people want to find out
about kids rank they want to either
donate or they want to volunteer look in
that camera and tell them where to go
you go to kids rank that Morgan thank
you so much definitely go check out the
site it's a wonderful site if you can
donate or volunteer they do so much good
definitely thank you so much
you